Olá D aland Dutra aqui no vídeo de hoje
vamos mergulhar no fascinante mundo da
coenzima q10 eu vou contar tudo em um
resumo simples e fácil quem se beneficia
do consumo por que que ela pode estar em
falta no seu corpo onde encontrá-la na
sua dieta E como que você vai
suplementar quando e como suplementar
agora pessoal imagine uma substância tão
essencial que todas suas células do
corpo precisam Essa é a coenzima q10 ela
protege nossa células contra o
envelhecimento e tem sido uma aliada na
batalha contra problemas cardíacos com
estudos indicando melhoria na função
cardíaca e redução no risco de morte por
causas cardiovasculares entre idosos que
usaram suplementos de qualqu 10 junto
com mineral selênio agora apesar de
nosso corpo ser capaz de produzir a sua
própria coenzima que 10 às vezes ele
precisa de um impulso adicional isso
porque muitas coisas podem fazer você
perder ou não fabricar adequadamente
essa coenzima tão fundamental a falta
dela pode abrir portas para o indesejado
estresse oxidativo que está por trás de
muitas condições preocupantes desde
diabetes e câncer até fibromialgia e
doenças cardíacas sem falar no temido
declínio cognitivo Olha que Fantástico
pessoal a fibromialgia é uma doença
desafiadora e debilitante marcada por
dor crônica e fadiga estudos têm
revelado que a coenzima q10 ela tem
demonstrado a capacidade de reduzir a
dor geral as dores de cabeça e a fadiga
trazendo um alívio tangível para aqueles
que sofrem dessa condição como um
poderoso antioxidante a coenzima q10
pode aumentar a absorção de outros
nutrientes essenciais e foi demonstrado
que ajuda a reciclar a vitamina C
vitamina E maximizando ainda mais os
seus efeitos pessoal ela é mais do que
um simples componente antioxidante ela é
o combustível das mitocôndrias as usinas
de energia de nossas células Por isso os
principais sintomas de falta dessa
coenzima são fadiga e dor muscular Mas
aqui está um fato preocupante conforme
envelhecemos a produção de coenzima
que10 pelo nosso corpo diminui e você
pode estar se perguntando o que que
causa a perda de coqu 10 ao longo da
vida bem eu já falei do envelhecimento
mas a resposta é
multifacetada Porém uma das causas pode
ser o uso de estatinas Esses
medicamentos prescritos para baixar o
colesterol podem ter o efeito colateral
indesejado de bloquear a formação de
coquis no corpo levando a miopatias
induzidas Por estatinas que se
manifestam como dores musculares
fraqueza e fadiga excessiva
especialmente durante exercícios doenças
crônicas como diabetes câncer
insuficiência cardíaca congestiva são
verdadeiros ladrões da enzima q10
roubando nossas reservas eles se juntam
às doenças mitocondriais estresse
crônico estresse oxidativo que afetam
diretamente as centrais de energia de
nossas células mas não é só a doença que
pode esgotar nossos estoques até mesmo o
que falta em nossa dieta pode ser um
problema as deficiências nutricionais
especialmente vitaminas no complexo B
vitamina C e ácido Alfa lipoico tem um
papel nessa deficiência nessa dinâmica
uma vez que esses nutrientes são
coadjuvantes na dança química que mantém
nossos níveis de cozema queed e como
podemos então naturalmente aumentar
nossos níveis de coenzima q10 através da
dieta a natureza nos oferece várias
opções desde o salmão selvagem sardinhas
até sementes de gelim pistache e
brócolis carnes de animais criados a
pasto frango orgânico e ovos também
estão na lista não podemos esquecer dos
vegetais ricos em Clorofila que quando
banhados pela luz do sol podem ajudar na
produção de coqu 10 pessoal quando
falamos de suplementação a coenzima q10
é um antioxidante solúvel em gordura O
que significa que a sua absorção é
maximizada quando acompanhada de
gorduras saudáveis e Existem duas formas
distintas dessa coenzima o bikin Ona e o
bikin o biquin é a forma reduzida da
qualquer 10 que é considerada uma
alternativa muito mais eficiente por ser
oito vezes melhor sua vida então quando
falamos de suplementação Eu
particularmente prefiro optar pela forma
em um biquin as dosagens dos Suplementos
podem variar mas a maioria dos
Suplementos está na faixa de 100 a 200
mg Porém para certas condições de saúde
podem ser necessárias outras doses agora
quando você deve tomar de manhã ou à
noite embora possa ser tomado a qualquer
hora que for mais conveniente é melhor
tomar como uma refeição que contenha
gordura e e se você tomar uma dose
superior a 100 mg por dia é melhor
dividir as doses em duas ou três porções
menores o que vai ajudar na absorção e
como qualquer suplemento é importante
estar ciente dos possíveis efeitos
colaterais que podem variar de leves a
mais incômodos como problemas digestivos
náusea tonturas ou insônia por isso é
sempre recomendado discutir com
profissional de saúde antes de começar a
tomar coqu 10 Muito obrigado pela sua
atenção um grande abraço e um beijo no
se oração você é feira